so in this talk I'm going to try and
prove to you that Bruce Lee was actually
one of the original software architects
in order for me to do that we'll have to
go back into time and we have to go back
into time when I went to college which
is about seven million years ago and
when I was in college I wanted to be the
best software programmer and best sofa
architect in the world I wanted to know
everything all right I wanted to be the
best of the best so I read all the books
you could find design petrus pragmatic
program a mythical man-month code
complete at first I read them all right
because I knew when I ripped all these
books I had all this knowledge and I
would be the best so I had this huge
library of books that I read and
interesting facts by the way if you want
to read a lot of books there's a very
good site called def books in this side
they maintain a list of all the most
recommended books on Stack Overflow now
the number one recommended books on sec
overflow is working effectively with
legacy code think about that for a
minute what this says about our industry
so I read all these books and I was in
love with these kind of diagrams these
were great right you Mel was my abacus
language basically if you could just
express everything in a UML diagram it
would be amazing I could be just write
it down and all I had to do is just
build it and it would be perfect and it
would be just right I was a strong
proponent of solid principles right I
mean my programs would be so solid they
would be solid like the Chinese wall you
could see them from outer space that's
how solid they would be right but I'm
gonna started to learn and read a little
bit about Bruce Lee and the way he
approach things and one of his saying is
noticed that the stiffest tree is most
easily cracked while the bamboo suffice
by bending with the wind and this always
stuck with me because I wrote all these
amazing software programs and I went to
my clients and my client said
do you know do you remember that thing I
told you about that was never gonna
change do you know that requirement that
wasn't important that little bit of tiny
information that actually was a really
big deal yeah so the thing we need you
to change the finger was not a big deal
that is a big deal and all the other you
know whatever you made is not important
to us so my perfect build diagram was
you know shattered my software program
was horrible and it was not my table etc
etc and I felt very bad because that
felt well I I made like an entire
diagram everything was so beautifully
laid out but it wasn't good enough and I
felt the same way when I was playing a
computer game Diablo most of you won't
know it anyway in Diablo you level up
you get her stuff you get her items you
get a levels etc etc and you get better
and better at the game so I'm a little
bit of a masochist so I played a
hardcore version which means that if you
die in the game you have to start all
over again so all the days weeks months
years of work you put into your
character gone and I felt the same way
when I lost my character when I felt
when I went yet another software project
ran wild basically but over time when I
lost more and more characters I feel
less bad about it oddly enough it's like
yeah another one died another software
project failed whatever right that's
kind of bad as well so the reason why
that happened is because whenever you
start a project this is your plan right
and this is what happens and this is
like a universal truth all right so
Bruce Lee capture that in life is never
stagnation it is constant movement
constant change because most software
projects basically work like this
they're more like a Chimaira I mean
there might like a compound I don't know
menagerie of all sorts of animals
there's a bit of a dragon in there a
lion a goat some wings and that's
because software projects change over
time a lot they go left they go right
they go up they go down a lot of them go
back
so and the reason for this is that
nobody writes perfect so far the first
time that's the biggest lie we keep
telling ourselves like we cannot do up
from the sign because we don't know
everything yet it's not gonna be perfect
well except this guy but there's only
one of him
right so let's talk about architecture
what is a Sofer architect anyone want to
guess apparently not so to me it's over
architectures or so for experts that
makes high-level design decisions and
choices about the technology uses tech
use including stuff like coding
standards etc etc right and as we all
know all architecture is design but not
all design is architecture so let's talk
about architecture more so what is this
sure it's very good
what's the function
ah okay what's another function magma
okay so this is a church and people come
here gather here and do prayer stuff
right so let's try another one what is
this what is this
okay so what's what's what's the goal
okay well actually they're two girls but
okay what's the function so I put a
bunch of people together and watch some
kind of bowl game right so this one is a
little bit harder what's this Ally very
very good library but we needed a little
bit of legenda to you know explain that
it's actually a library right so we look
at these architectures and they're
pretty clear even though we're not
experts on you know stadiums and
libraries I think so anyway I'm not but
we can pretty much figure out what it
does right so Bruce Lee said those who
are unaware they are walking in the
darkness will never seek the light so
let's do this exact exact same
experiment but let's you suffer so what
is this who can tell me which language
this is Ruby any specific form of Ruby
where else very good
what does it do okay that's a little bit
of you know like a tricky question I
mean we all know it's Ruby on Rails and
it uses MVC structure so let's look at
the MVC triads right to see what it does
so we have an app we have some
controller's helpers models a fuse
everybody knows or it's taught that all
the business logic is always in the
model so we can probably figure out what
it does by looking in the models so here
we go so who knows what this does except
suck
so let's help you bit so we have let's
see it's like an issue tracker very very
good very good sir so actually it is an
issue tracker if you look at the
controllers which tell us everything we
need to know because we have a Gans
controller and a files controller
obviously this is an issue tracker so
this is red line open-source project
that does project management and issue
tracking and I know what you're thinking
ah but this is Ruby we don't do Ruby I
mean that's not fair so let's try again
what's this language Wow larval very
good what does he do things laravel
things okay well okay let's let's again
try and figure out what this do by
looking at M fishy try it's right so we
have an app it has stuff in it commands
console includes library it has ninja
holy-moly it doesn't India amazing so
let's look at ninja first because ninja
so yeah Ninja has data tables import
intense mailers notification payment
drivers presenters repository
serializers and transformers obviously
ninja right I know what you're thinking
ninja are notorious for hiding their
intent so obviously they're hiding their
intent here so let's look at the models
again so we have a count pretty good we
have bank we have invitation invoice we
have subscription tasks anyone want to
guess
ninja his voice very good the first one
will actually get it so this is a
personal you know invoicing piece of
software which you can see obviously by
the controllers so this is my problem
when we approach so far as so for
architecture and software development
when I open up a legacy program project
preferably not written by me I have no
clue what it does and usually the readme
doesn't help me
so to give a very simple example of this
let's build a house the way we would
build sulphur and I will use Symphony as
an example here just for people say okay
so this is a house bundle because it's
Symphony so if a command go to bed and
get dressed we have some controllers
with bet controller and close control
and stairs controller we have entity
instead of model because reasons so we
have cement and floor and wall and it's
a bunch of stuff and with some surfaces
like change room surface and we have
sleep surface so simple question how
many floors does this house have that's
got a bed house right if you don't know
how many floors to this how many stairs
does this house have no in there doesn't
have stairs is it an apartment maybe do
we care so if I would approach this if I
was you know built actually a house
probably look more like this so in
actual house there's a first floor and
the second floor and in the you know on
the floor so there's some rooms and in
the rooms is that some stuff in it but
the way we build software now if we
would do that you know as actual
builders it would be like okay let's put
all the walls over here let's put all
the doors over here yeah the the windows
over here and yeah a bunch of stairs
let's put them here right this this is
how we build software this is our
architecture so what if we lost in the
last few decades about keeping it simple
why don't we just you know write it down
the way it's supposed to be did we
forget this fundamental rule so I came
across this notion which all stuck by me
the junior hard coats it the media
creates an abstract factory for it and a
senior heart cuts it I don't know who I
can attribute this to us probably Bruce
Lee so when I was reading about Bruce
Lee
it stuck to me that his life time or is
his entire life journey very closely
relates to how software works so when
Bruce Lee was younger about 12 he went
to school he grew up in Bangkok and
there were a lot of gangs and rifle
gangs in Bangkok and they would just
beat random people up just for the fun
of it because that's what they do
so Bruce Lee was you know beat up a lot
as a kid
and he learned to fight that let die
that way so he's on the streets and he
got jumped and he took everything he was
fine like if there was a rock on the
floor he would use the rock if he could
kick someone he would kick if you could
punch someone he would punch but
basically everything in his surroundings
he started using just you know to not
get beat up by gangs but when he got a
little bit older around 16 he felt well
this fighting thing isn't working out
that well there's probably people who
actually know how to fight right so
maybe I should learn that so I went to
this guy a very famous teacher called it
man and he became a student in Wing Chun
which is a subsection of kung-fu so he
went to rigorous training he studied all
the difference martial arts there are so
sneaky and crane or more popularly known
as in the west's crane tiger every form
of kung fu you can think of he studied
right
and he started name rigorously and - the
book the funny thing was doubt at every
sensei every teacher he came across all
told him the same thing our kung-fu is
the best if you know our kung fu you can
solve any problem you encounter this is
kind of weird because there's like I
don't know
thousands of versions of kung fu and
everyone said the exact same thing and
this is kind of how we approach software
if you do functional programming
this is the best paradigm if we do
object-oriented programming
this is the best paradigm if you do
design patterns these are the best
design patterns right if you use these
religiously everything will be fine and
in my opinion
that's pretty wrong so it doesn't matter
if you use PHP or Ruby or whatever I
mean they all have something in them so
he studied them all even drunken men
kung-fu and I'll leave up to your
imagination to what that you know
relates to the only finger was different
about come Bruce Lee than the rest of
the students was that Bruce Lee was not
a fool born Chinese guy he was a model
or half-blood as they say his father was
an American and actually you weren't
allowed to teach kung fu to non Chinese
people then so he had to train a lot of
the times alone like you know smashing
into a rock or into tree etc etc so
while everyone was very indoctrinated by
the kung fu mentality he personally had
a little bit of a different outcome or a
few about the entire kung-fu world so at
some point in his life he became what we
call enlightened he saw that all these
different forms of kung foo have
something useful in them and at some
point in time or some certain situations
you can use that kung fu to solve a
problem and also what he realized was
that in every kung fu people approach
you straight on and then you do a move
and you win but in real life he thought
that well maybe I got jacked from behind
most of the time and that doesn't help
me at all so he came up with this he was
only that which works and take it and
take it from any place you can find it
and he took that to the extreme and
designed his entire own version of kung
fu which basically means grab all the
things I find useful and put it together
and he called it Jeet Kune Do roughly
translated Bruce Lee's is kung fu which
is not true but I'd like to hope so so
the core rules of Jeet kun da are three
basic rules efficiency directness and
simplicity efficiency is an attack which
uses the target in the least amount of
time with maximum force directness doing
what comes naturally in a disciplined
way and simplicity thinking in an
uncomplicated manner without
ornamentation right
so he summed it up in this the less
effort the faster I'm powerful you will
be now I'm not going to say that Bruce
Lee was the first agile coach ever but
you couldn't make that point so let me
introduce you to Bruce Lee driven
development also known as jute Qingdao
we already have TDD we already have
Diddley BDD so now we have BL DD right
so first rule of BL DD begin at the core
but what is the core of your application
right what what are we talking about
here so the focus on the core here
shifts to whenever you start something
new a new project a new problem space
don't think well I'm gonna need PHP and
I'm that's new framework X and I need
like memcache and read is and my sequel
database and the less exert and all
these things do not do don't do anything
to solve your problem they're just tools
that we use to fix a certain problem so
just focus on what your active trying to
solve and to figure out what that is
there's a very good book by Eric Evans
called domain driven design I certainly
recommend you read it and one of the
things it talks about a lot is
communication what they call you bit do
ubiquitous language and to give you an
example how that in how that affects
your project raise of hands how many see
you white dress how many see blue dress
so this is the core at what software
communication is a problem off we can
all both talk about the same thing but
mean different things right that doesn't
mean one or one of them is wrong it just
means we have a different view on them
so the lesson learned here is that
effective communication is very hard to
do and Bruce Lee said this in order to
taste my cup of water you must first
empty your cup what he meant means by
that is whenever you get a problem in
front of you don't just start thinking
about solution immediately first talk to
whatever ask the problem and try to find
out if it's the actual problem
or it's just they think that that's a
problem right you can only do that if
you feel if you empty your own cup
because else you all have these pre you
know pre solutions that you're trying to
try and steer the conversation to so the
most important lesson air is listening
right ii recognize the value what is the
value of what we're trying to do so I'll
give you a very simple example
that's a kung-fu master I want to travel
fast to dojos so I can prove I'm the
best right now the focus and the value
is here in travel and fast alright so if
you would build this and we say well a
car is very fast so we're gonna build a
car the first three steps of that
process we don't achieve any value we
only achieve value at the end right
whereas if we take this approach where
we first see Bruce Lee on a skateboard
and then on a step and then on a bicycle
he still gets to travel only the fast
part that comes later but we have
instant value here right so when the
value goes up the project is probably
gonna succeed so always keep asking
yourself what is the value what we're
trying to do what is it actually what
we're trying to do right well if he does
with this piece of wisdom great so for
today is often preferable to perfect
software tomorrow so I know what a what
happens a lot in these cases so he built
those four stages right the skelter and
the bicycle and then a new guy comes in
looks at it assists why didn't you just
build an airplane right because that
travels the fastest but this is what we
call insight afterwards right 20/20
vision so the key to immortality is
first living a life worth remembering we
first need to get to that point before
we can even consider something like an
airplane because as a first step it's
way too expensive right so next one use
the simplest most direct approach first
and I mean it in the most little literal
way so find X there it is
sometimes the easiest and simplest
solution can be good enough it's easy to
change easy to extract easy to refactor
so try to direct approach first right
you don't know if you need anything more
complex than this to give you an example
what it looks like if you have three
balls going down a ramp most people
think that the top one will be the most
efficient and most people will think
that the bottom one would be the slowest
so let's find out as you can see the top
one is actually the slowest all right
so next rule change is inevitable we
talked about this before we cannot you
know see the future we cannot abstract
things away if we don't have all the
information premature abstraction is the
root of all evil so you should write
your code in a way that is easy
deletable and I mean that's quite
literally right because if your code is
deletable it's can self contained it's
you know decouple there's all those good
things we want and if you need to change
your code that's what is useful reject
what it's useless and add what is
specifically your own all right so let's
talk about one of in my opinion most on
a less understood principle let's talk
about dry so who here does not know what
dry means okay so so dry is an acronym
for don't repeat yourself right and it's
closely aligned to the single
responsibility principle but that's a
whole nother story so what we say is if
you have some piece of code it should
just be dead piece of codes that's
responsible for a thing right don't have
like seven different things in your
application that do the same thing so
most easiest would be I don't know a
helper clause that's four months at a
time something like that right you don't
want seventeen different things for
money and you just want one thing
but this is true in all occasions so
let's look at a real-life example let's
say you have a product you want to sell
and you have a sales team that wants to
sell the product and a.f potential
customers right they're not customers
yet there are potential customers and
these customers have specific
territories we're talking about a global
I don't know eBay Amazon thing so
there's a lot of points of sale here
there's a lot of opportunities what is
the information that a salesperson needs
from this customer in this product well
specifically for the product a price the
sale price maybe some how do you call it
some deduction II can give you to make
the deal from the customer even probably
wants to know like a profile that the
customer is in so he knows a little bit
what the spending budget is etc etc so
the wishes of someone who's in sales
about a customer and project is very
different than someone who is for
example in support if you're in support
you have the customer already so you
don't really care about the profile
anymore you care about whatever you
bought what is the warranty on the thing
is the specific firmware version as he
runs etcetera etcetera what is he a very
good customer like does he always pay on
time stuff like that right and the
product is the same thing like I said
warranty we don't care about the selling
price it's already bought right has it
previous being defect etc etc so even
though we have customer and product in
our application and this is just two use
cases they have very different needs so
my answer to that is do repeat yourself
so we keep dry but do it with intent
right optimized for the specific use
cases that you need them for
and with this bit of thing is delay any
major decisions about these kinds of
optimizations to the very last moment
but no later right so final rule
experiment this is a bit of a
controversial one when you're beforehand
so try different experiments when you're
building something and the reason for
this is usually
most models are wrong but some are
useful and we are interested in the
useful ones right so there's a technique
you can use it's called small controlled
experiment where you do like one little
thing and you do it for a certain amount
of time and then you discuss with your
team or with the company if it's a
positive or a negative outcome right
does it help us or not and if it's
positive most likely that you keep it
and if it's negative if you don't do it
again
right but you need this environment
where you can experiment because if
you're training to be a kung-fu master
you probably want to start training at
this age and you want to be have an
opponent that's also of the same age
right because it's kind of mean to get
something to be a kung-fu master
starting like this and there was a story
recently where some junior developer had
straight access to the live database and
accidentally to the live database away
this so remember though mistakes are
always forgivable if one has the courage
to omit them like we need to make
mistakes to learn to grow to get better
so your organization should provide that
safe space all right so resume the most
important parts about Bruce Lee driven
the belphin kind of spoiled it didn't
they so begin at the core recognize the
value of what you're doing
use the simplest most direct approach
first change is inevitable an experiment
so aren't we just chained you know
exchanging some set of rules for another
no because Bruce Lee said a goal is not
always meant to be reached it often
serves simply as something to aim at all
right it doesn't mean we need to
strictly do this it's just try them out
see if they're useful see if they help
you and then use more of it or less of
it so I talked in the beginning about
all the books and this is one of the
most influential one in my opinion
design patrons element of reusable
object-oriented software what about
these patterns right so we just burn all
these books forget about them that would
be a little
harsh so Bruce Lee said this obey the
principles without being bound by them
so keep using all these things just be
wary of when you use them right so if
you're interested or want to learn about
this how do you start how do you start
being a beat LDD advocates well Bruce
Lee said this if you want to learn to
swim jump into the water on dry land no
frame of mind is ever going to help you
and I feel this is very much true in
software we talk about a lot of
technological stuff and we have a lot of
discussion but actually building
something is usually the easiest and
best way to learn so I'll leave you with
these thoughts don't get set into one
form adapt it and build your own let it
grow be like water my friends be like
water thank you
[Applause]